greetings from podcastville it's monday
december 14th
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
blue chew everyone knows the best give
the best gift you can give is love
this christmas if you're not unwrapping
a big fat
dick you're missing the [__] out
[__]
blue chew you're like joey what the [__]
are you talking about i'm talking about
it's the holiday season you're in the
spirit of giving
part of that giving is giving out some
[__] sperm juice
to some [__] donors you understand me
and
listen for some of you your dick is
[__] still tip top magoo
for others it's 70 60
50 why take a chance blue chew
the first chewable dick pill fda
approved
applicant active ingredients as viagra
and cialis blue chew is prescribed
online
by a licensed physician so you don't got
to go to the doctor's office
and make eye contact with a creepy
[__] doctor and then go wait online
and the [__] three chicks behind the
[__] pharmacy no you suffer from
[__] erectile dysfunction
i'm telling you even if you don't suffer
from erectile dysfunction
right here you don't want to show up
with [__]
four bullets when you got a chamber for
six right or wrong
blue chew you show up with that dick
that looks like a [__] bam bam stick
and it'll be all over the shouting right
now they got a special offer
for the holidays for the for the joint
family you ready
visit bluechew.com that's blue
b-l-u-e like the [__] color of your
[__]
when you eat one of these [__] things
afterwards what they're gonna do is go
to bluetooth.com and get your first
shipment
free joey what are you talking about
[__] free
you pay for shipping that's it that's
it and that's that bluetooth.com
use code joey again i'm gonna give you
go to bluetooth.com get your first
shipment free
when you press in code joey just pay the
fin
five dollars is a thing to get in the
shipping
and that's it and that's that that's how
i'm gonna take care of the holidays
so right now go to bluechew.com
code joey the joint is also brought to
you by
mac weldon i don't know if you
[__] have checked the [__]
weather report
it's gonna snow this week and listen i
don't want you to be cold i don't want
your little nuts to be cold
i got some mac welding long underwear
they're [__] tremendous you
understand me mac walden
has the best when it comes to men's
basics
[__] done whether it's warm knit top
or
sunday lounge pants everyone on your
list can be comfortable listen
mac walden is great because you don't
have to leave your [__] house
this is it you're looking for a gift for
somebody it's all in your fingertips
socks shirts
hoodies underwear polos or active shirts
mac walden is comfortable and versatile
do me a favor
win this gift-giving season and get 20
off
your first order right now matt weldon
off your first order when you visit
macweldon.com
join that's joint enter promo code joint
i'm getting you 20 off this is it
long underwear socks the [__] long
underwear tremendous they're tight
around the ankles
they it's it's like like having like
those uh
those pants on under you jiu-jitsu it
keeps everything nice and warm
and i sit down my [__] recliner my
nut sack is nice and warm
they're tremendous listen long underwear
season is in
mack weldon is the way to go especially
now that you christmas shopping
right now go to macweldon.com join
that's mackwalden.com
for 20 off matt weldon
reinventing men's basics the joint is
also brought to you by honey listen
you got a lot of gifts you got to buy
right now right you got like 18
[__] brothers you got big kids you
got the wife the mother-in-law
this [__] adds up what if i told you i'd
get you a little help i'm paying for you
all your little gifts there
well that's what honey is doing to help
them pay for 1 million bucks
worth the gifts the only way santa's
coming down
my [__] chimney is if he's covered in
honey you understand me
listen honey goes right to your computer
you create a free account
and they throw some gifts on your drop
list for a chance to win okay
this is this honey is the company that
automatically searches
for promo codes online before you buy
anything this is it you know
i got a bunch of stuff on my christmas
list for mercy
i'm gonna go through honey first and see
if i get a little
you know promo code there why not what
are we
[__] uh millionaires here nobody so
plus with honey
they'll tell you when the price drops on
anything
on your list go to honey right now get a
get a free
join honey dot com slash joey
create your list for a chance to win
here's the lawyer part
no purchase necessary you need a paypal
account to redeem your prize
only valid and the u.s giveaway
ends 12 21 of
2020 that's next week but you can win at
joinhoney.com joey
i want to thank honey bluechu.com
and mackweldon.com putting the joint
together
here we go [__]
candles lit let's get this party started
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here on a beautiful
[__] monday morning it's snowing who
gives a [__]
we still got to do what we got to do we
got to come through strong
we got [__] 11 whether you're nine
shoplifting days
before christmas i know you're stressed
i know you don't know what you get your
cousin your sister-in-law
but [__] it it's all over you belong to
me for this [__] hour
we alleviate all that [__] who gives a
[__] about christmas presents
do what i do go out on the 24th when
everything is [__] empty
and you got the story yourself you don't
have much of a selection
and it's less [__] confusing i
actually actually tried
to go christmas shopping on [__]
saturday
it was [__] rough i tried to get my
wife something you got to get him
something
so i went to the store at the [__]
mall and it was huge it was three floors
and the more i walked in with the mask i
brought glasses and
once your glasses start fogging up my
[__] anxiety goes up 100 over [__]
den
i looked at a couple things and i ran
the [__] out of there i was gonna call
her but she was at a friend's house
her and my daughter were making cookies
with a bunch of kids i didn't want to
[__] tell her
listen you want christmas present you're
going to take a rabbit down with me to
the mall
and you can pick it out and i just give
you the doe for it because i don't have
the [__] patience
i really don't anymore guys i it's
it's too [__] heavy so there's some
people who like the [__] shop
me i like the shop but it's got to be
if you ever go clothes shopping with me
you'll get sick to your stomach
you're like joy what the [__] are you
doing because i just take [__] off the
thing
some little guy's chasing me would you
like to try it on do i look like i want
to try [__] on
i'm 300 pounds i got to take sneakers
off pants
put another thing i'm breathing heavy
i'll try it in at home if it don't work
i'll show up in three weeks for every
sneak
and nine out of ten i bring the ship
back to [__]
the homeless shelter or some [__] i just
i i don't like it i've never been a big
shopper i can't stand in there the other
thing i got patience for
is albums i go into a record store
[__] sit there for hours me and dean
delray used to do it all the time in the
cities
and just scroll through [__] albums i
do with jim florentine
we go to vintage vinyl or the other
joint down in asbury
and you're there an hour i want a
[__] half i can't sit
in the store for an hour and a half if
you [__] paid me i just walk through
and i look at different things
and 9 out of 10 the [__] you go looking
for
you don't find it's the [__] that you
find that you're not looking for
you're like wow this is a [__]
treasure
that's what i like but [__] regular
people shopping
has never [__] been for me i want to
thank all you guys for all your messages
and well wishes on my knee surgery
got pushed back january 8th
december 18th it's you know what i was
listening i just want to get it over
with
if you know anything about me the pain
has been getting worse
and i don't know what the [__] happened
it's either the stairs in the new house
or me that i i think i stopped i stopped
going to cryotherapy
you know i stopped going to red light
laser i stopped [__] going
acupuncture
i haven't found new people here people
every weekend have you have you gotten a
p.o box yet cocksuck i haven't even
found an acupuncturist
i haven't found [__] every week is a new
adventure
last week i had to find the studio so i
could put like
adr work for the many saints in newark
and i could lay down
tracks for [__] uh ozzie's boneyard
so it seems
it feels a lot better you know i could
do it it sounds better so i just found
the studio
it's close to the house the many saints
in newark
is ready to rock march 12th a lot of you
people aren't excited
people are like oh joey it's not coming
to the movie what do you want to do
what do you want me to [__] do you
know everybody's mad at [__] warner
brothers what do you want
warner brothers is sitting on it's got
to be
three quarters you know they're like a
billion dollars away in inventory in
movies
if you look at wonder woman many saints
the denzel movie
what do you what do you think when you
make an investment don't you want your
money back right away
okay then then what the [__] everybody's
yelling and screaming at warner brothers
they're not waiting for the movie to
we'll find me a movie thing that's
[__] open
what are you gonna do there's no [__]
movie theaters that are open
you know i was dreaming of the big
hollywood premiere and the [__]
going into the city and taking my wife
and having a great dinner and then
going on a thing it don't look like it
it's my [__] 11th
march 4th to march 5th usually do a
premiere a week before the [__] movie
how we're going to be walking around
what do you want to watch a movie with
people with [__] mascot huh
that doesn't sound like fun to me so
that's the only way they could release
on the streaming service
you accept it you know well we're not
going to get paid on the back end you're
not going to do this listen
you got everybody has to consider
something coveted means you're going to
lose money
you're going to sacrifice somebody
called me up and they go aren't you mad
that you're not going to get residuals
what what you have to sacrifice a little
bit you gotta be a team player a little
bit
i'm gonna no don't release the movie
because i'm not gonna make any back end
on it
i'd rather you see the [__] movie and
we'll worry about the back end later
it'll come to me some anyway
if i have it coming i have it coming
right or wrong so maybe they'll put it
on hbo max and they'll re-release it
i don't [__] know and i don't care
but i'm just telling you that it's not
such a [__] big deal
i'm in the [__] movie and i'm not mad
well
i wanted to be on the big screen who
gives a [__] i'm just grateful i was in
the [__] movie that they gave me a
[__] chance
to do the best that i can the movie
comes on hbo max
you either get it oh you [__] don't i
didn't [__] get it
when they did that hbo special with
colin quinn and bonnie and
i didn't even know what it was the hbo
max was you can't get it on your tv
unless you got a smart [__] tv
which i don't have a [__] smart tv i
don't have an app [__] tv
so you got to put it on your [__]
streaming device so anytime i want to
watch the sopranos or anything on hbo
they got 10 to midnight on there with
charles bronson
they got a bunch of old school [__]
movies i gotta watch it on my ipad i
don't [__] mind i sit in a [__]
chair
and i watch it i don't [__] play
anybody put my glasses on it's the best
they got
it's the best they got but the many
saints if you're excited about it
march 12th hbo max they got a 20
discount sticker you got to find it
online so if you sign up for six months
you get [__] 20 off you know in
advance
that's the best i can do for you i'm
just trying to save you a little money
i know you're upset that you're not
going to go to the movies but hey
i'm upset that we're not doing a lot of
[__] things somebody said something
to me the other day i i didn't enjoy it
because
they didn't have this a stupid it's
[__] coveted season
if you were in california you wouldn't
even have the opportunity to be in a
[__] restaurant
so take what governor murphy's given
shut your [__] mouth and deal with it
that's it that's all you can do half the
country three quarters of the countries
are locked down
they're jumping up and down in arizona
and jumping up and down to [__] texas
and they're jumping up and down in
florida everybody else is sitting here
on our [__] hands we're here at least
new jersey
we got 25 capacity the governor said
that [__]
he's not going to shut restaurants down
because he doesn't want to take away
their livelihood which
you know if it's not getting transmitted
in the restaurant
and all this [__] we know already you
know wear a mask
wash your hands wash your dick before
you [__]
wash your hands before you touch your
dick very important you don't want to
pass colgan on
to one of your [__] victims
because you didn't want to wash your
hands
and you grabbed your dick and pissed
that's not that's not right
and ladies don't scratch your [__]
snatch either
with your long fingernails and you get
in there and you got a little covert on
your finger now
and then a poor soul like mike not me
i'm through all the bees and [__]
victims [__]
he's your [__] and next you know they
got a [__] sore throat
and they're [__] hearing chinese
music because you didn't want to wash
your hands wash your hands
and scrub your [__] nails [__]
that's the season to be jolly
anyway let me talk to you [__]
about something
i'm happy the surgery wasn't done on the
18th something really weird happened
i told somebody i was having a surgery
on the 18th
and they're like hey man that's my
anniversary that's
the day that this and this and this
happened in my life
i told somebody else i was having
surgery on december 18
and they're like hey man that's my
anniversary of this
that's the day i ran over this guy with
a car like everybody's got a story
about [__] december 18th and i'm like
what you know what's crazy too that it's
the night i won the boulder broker
in 91 you know and
when it comes to comedy i hold you know
my touring with rogan sacred i hold my
knights at the store
close to my heart i hold the longest
yard close to my heart i hold the many
saints close to my heart
you know these are things i did that i'm
really proud of on paper
spider-man 2 you know how i dug it out
all those years
[__] sleeping in cars and being on
bus stations
and sacrificing all that shit's great
and i got to do it you know
and the [__] ari things on comedy
central
i'm really grateful for those who gave
people
another different aspect to look at what
i had to offer which is
i'm more of a storyteller than a joke
teller you know what i'm saying
i don't know how to write jokes really
well like bill burr
knows how to put together a [__] bit
that's brilliant i don't know how to do
that
and i'm not [__] crying about it
just some people are stronger in some
areas than others you know
but i was thinking about december 18th
and this
it's it really has to do with the switch
remember a couple weeks ago
we were talking about that switch that
goes off naturally
when you win the war against yourself
listen bro all is fair and love and war
right they
always tell you that since you're a kid
if you get cheated on
or if you you know if you're playing
[__] you ever play combat when you're
a kid
and you're only allowed to throw like
twigs but you end up throwing like a
[__] rock and you hit the kid in the
head and the kids like
you weren't allowed to throw rocks yeah
all's fans love them walk [__]
next time that's why the nazis wore
helmets because one
got hit with a head next time get a
[__] helmet and you won't get hit in
the head with the [__] rock
i mean all's fan loving war you know i'm
not
talking about cheating i'm not talking
about sometimes
in life this is a [__] war guys
you busting out through the other side
is really an internal
[__] war just think about
what i'm saying to you right now you're
looking at me going huh
you know all this processing deciding
what we're going to do and then deciding
that we're going to go for it
and then the switch going off is you
winning the war
against yourself the biggest enemy you
have
is yourself you know when you look in
the mirror
and when you're [__] putting on your
tie going for that interview
and that right there's a deciding
[__] thing you're telling yourself
i'm not gonna get it
you know i've been on 19 interviews i'm
overqualified you're losing the war
right there
you're losing the war right there like
you're just losing it right there
you know uh
the war is real but the war starts with
you
you think you're at war with the world
everybody who has you know well nobody's
given me a chance
nobody's doing this nobody's giving me a
break it's the [__] world and listen
i'm not lying to you fifty percent
you're right 50
of it is the world but the other 50
of it is the war you inflict upon
yourself
how do i know about this war because i
was part of it
i had a war going on myself for years i
struggled with the addictions and
this is the last time i'm gonna do coke
and lying to yourself and you know
not being honest with yourself but that
has nothing to do with the internal war
the internal war is you deciding what
you want to do
putting your head down and doing it you
know what
if i take this job it pays a lot of
money but i'm away from my wife and kids
for the whole week i won't see them till
saturday and sunday
talk to your wife does she rather keep
[__] eating
[__] uh tv dinners or does she want
to live a normal life
you know and and this is what you need
to do you need to go down there
you need to sleep on your uncle's couch
six nights a week it's gonna be rough
but until you get out of this [__]
hole if you plan it right
and there's no flat tires and the
transmission don't go you're
saying like you know like when you're
saving money for something then the
transmission goes
and you're back to square one but man if
you're sincere in your heart
and you're really [__] working hard
nothing should be going wrong
and your plan should hatch it's not
always gonna
[__] work out the way you want it to
something's gonna break along the way
you know oh i make [__] two thousand
miles a week now
so in six weeks i get out of my debt and
then your [__] garage door falls on
your cat
and now you gotta [__] you know pay
for a garage door there's always
something
that's a part of life that's a part of
life that has
nothing to do with you
this is what people will [__] take
this [__] personally
and they go the world's got it out for
me the world don't even know you [__]
exist you [__] megan
did you think the world know who i was
when i was 28
and out of jail and wanted to do comedy
the world didn't give a [__]
who joey was they don't really and they
don't give a [__] where you were
i know you my dad is you know the
the president of [__] a spokesman
associate
your dad is a dick your dad can go [__]
himself he's a [__] pimple
on a [__] on a dog's ass
right now the world don't care about you
so the world don't even know you [__]
exist
you're blaming all this [__] on this
that the media
the politicians they don't even know you
[__] exist what do you think they
looked at your name when you voted they
don't give a [__] to you but we
you have a vote and get a christmas card
from the [__] mayor no
they don't give a [__] that you voted
they don't know names they don't know
nothing
but nobody cares about you
you they really [__] don't and when
you get that through your head that
nobody gives a [__] about me
and there's no conspiracy against me all
you [__] that
things go wrong that's a conspiracy yeah
there's no conspiracy
god doesn't have it out for you you got
it out for you
you got it out for you you keep giving
yourself excuses
and saying all this [__] to yourself but
anyway let's get back to the [__] uh
the moral of the [__] story
so i had something big that happened
december 18th
and i didn't realize it until like
they called when they called and they
said we're pushing your surgery back to
the eight they push it back to the
eighth
because my ekg my heart is listen my
heart is great
i walked the pills for [__] 20 years
in north bergen second hilliest
city in the country i did blow for 20
years yeah i put the little dent in the
[__] armor
and the sleep apnea don't help it but
the walking
and the [__] heart that i have and
the heart that you know just the
just the push that i had in my heart
it's just having a regular heartbeat and
a lot of you guys have been
hitting me up my dad had it but you're
going to be fine they got to re-tune
your heart
it's going to be fine i'll be slinging
dick by january 8th i got to go for a
test on the 23rd
i got to go for a test on the [__]
30th who wants to do anything on the
[__] 30th
the year is over leave me alone and then
i got to go
uh for clearance on the 23rd it's on the
22nd
to the doctor and that's it the eighth i
go in there i get this [__] knee done
i got a show on the six at uncle vinnie
just to let you know
i'm not [__] around if you came to
uncle vinnie's last week
thank you very much we had a great
[__] time great show
i mean you know i'm i'm sick in my heart
that
the club is closed on the 23rd and
[__]
i'm gonna be free for seven or eight
nights i mean i've been talking to rich
voss and jimmy and what we gotta figure
something out
but that's not the situation at hand the
situation at hand was i was thinking
about december 18th
and you know what i underestimated
it's up there with all like [__]
really good accomplishments
and it's not the accomplishment that i
won the contest
that wasn't all it i gotta turn the
story back
on you to let you know what happened so
i get into comedy july in 91.
soon as i get off the stage i i i i was
just you know i had found what i had
been looking for i was like youtube
well i still fun no
i found it i found it and on the way
home in the car my head couldn't
comprehend it
but i was a working stiff and there was
nothing i could do to change that
this is what i had responsibilities
stand-up was not gonna [__] happen
you know
the night that i did the comedy works
july 18th
somebody offered me a gig the next night
they were like god you were great his
name was
pj moore god rest his soul great comic
great kid him and this guy bill
uh can't remember his name
they booked a room called the greely
underground it was in greeley colorado
and it was called the underground and
for you people don't know greeley is
also the
where the broncos do pre-season training
so i got into comedy july 18th
and they were still doing like the
pre-season but no quarterbacks or
it was just like running and workouts i
guess i really don't know what it's
called
so he asked me he goes do you want to go
to the broncos training facility
tomorrow night and do that gig and i was
like
[__] yeah i was petrified don't get me
wrong
but you know when you're coming off the
stage you're on such a high
that somebody says do you want to suck a
dick you're like yeah i don't care you
know
i just had the best [__] time in my
life
so he offers me the gig i take it
and the next day i go to greely i bomb
you know no big [__] deal
it's all now you know you had you had
your big high
and now you got your big low and now i'm
stable again
and i'm trying to figure out how to do
comedy and blah blah blah
i'm just not right in the head i'm not
in love anymore
there was a part of me i didn't want a
[__] family anymore
i just wanted to do stand up i had i had
felt that i had
found my calling you know
and i came to new york before
my wife came to me little did i know
that
now something happened and that's why
she was sending me away
to make her a little [__] weak of
love easier
and i went to new york i stayed for like
eight days
i got high every [__] night i was
just i just came here to
do cocaine i hadn't been home in six
years so i basically
came home to do coke with my friends
that i hadn't seen
in six years i came home
i went back to new york i stayed for
[__] a week i got high and i went
back to colorado
and after that we had like a month on
the marriage was on basic life support
i just knew i wanted to do comedy and in
the middle of all this
i don't know how i don't know
how this [__] happened i
was reading a paper a boulder newspaper
or something
and i saw the boulder
broker was doing a comedy contest
it was the beck's
broker joker comedy competition now
a secret to a lot of guys a lot of you
guys don't know
is right after i got
on stage the first time
somebody oh johnny walker
black and red was doing an open call
for comedians to do a contest
i actually called in sick put on my
jacket and shirt and went down to the
denver comedy works
this is way before i ever got on stage
and i went to this ambition to this
nbc this [__] johnny walker black
uh red whatever the [__] you call it
competition and i get there and i sign
my name and i'm you know in my mind i
got the best three minutes
and the next thing you know i walk in
there and i see all the i did not
know any of these comics i didn't
recognize any of them
but they all had like shirts on that
intimidated me
like right now i got like a [__]
the ice house in pasadena i shot out i
miss you [__]
the ice house of pasadena well all these
guys had like on like you know
labs t-shirts comedy works t-shirts
the guy that cracked me was a guy that
had a jacket that had an nbc peacock on
it
and i was like [__] this i'm losing i'm
getting the [__] out of here
so that was the beginning of my comedy
thing big time [__]
you know ran away from contests and then
there was another contest
to do something and i ran away from that
one too
i'm not gonna lie to you so
i get this paper thing i'm still married
i'm super [__] unhappy and i see this
ad in the paper at the broker
the broker was a restaurant and there
were chains there was four of them
there was like the woman's bank in
denver there was one out in lakewood
there was another one in downtown i
think there was two of them in downtown
denver
cool places really different old school
you know people had vests on like the
bank the women's bank and then
in downtown denver was basically a bank
and you ate where they give you the
safety deposit boxes you have a safe
deposit box
they bring it to you and they close the
door they converted those into little
boots
so you and your girlfriend could just
eat in the boot they had a curtain
they bring you a bowl of shrimp you
could finger bang them before the
appetizers come
you don't know how many times i ate a
girl's [__] before the appetizers came
in those [__] broken jokers those uh
those broker restaurants
but the one in bold i had never really
been to i had been there one time
they had the best [__] sunday brunch
ever the number one
sunday brunch back then i don't know
what's going on now
don't quote me i'm just giving you some
[__] knowledge
right here because you know i'm a fat
[__] and i love my [__] food
let me tell you something the best
sunday brunch
that i ever went to my life was that
[__]
where they shot the shining and that's
just park hotel whatever the
uh i don't know what the name of the
hotel is please because you people start
sending me emails joey you [__] up
fact check you know okay wherever they
shot the shiny
that hotel has
the best brunch on a [__] sunday
you've ever eaten that in your life
but it's esther's park it's towards
esther's park like a couple minutes away
from estes parks just a few hours by the
way essence park
is one of the most number one travel
destination in the country has this park
it's gorgeous you go up there they have
little squirrels that [__]
you could feed them they don't give you
a [__] tetanus shot whatever the [__]
syphilis i don't know what the [__]
squirrel gives you but they don't give
you another
[__] the stanley hotel this is the
stanley hotel like that i think
do not quote me on any of this i'm
talking to you [__] about 1991.
so the broker at the time had two things
going
they had wednesday nights which is
professional night
in other words uh fat chick
suck black dick night that's what it was
a bunch of fat little blonde chicks with
fake blonde hair
and black dudes were coming and [__]
from the college and
coming their mouths they gave you free
shrimp and they had some food out
and they had a happy hour i don't know
what it was called it was called like
wednesday afternoon social
and then friday up at the other hotel on
on
arapahoe boulevard that was the original
friday afternoon club
fac that made it to playboy that's like
the top five pickup spots in the [__]
country
i never went there i could you know i
could i could tell you that i went there
that quaaludes
i was i was into a different head i'm
not into [__] bars
on a friday afternoon but i would drive
by there
and guys there would be cars
in the hundreds and the hundreds
there was a supermarket and something
else there would be
cars parked down the road like
like a like a like the parkway in jersey
like was on the side of this hotel
there would be cars parked for two miles
from how many people would go to this
fac but none of this [__] matters it
doesn't matter
i'm just telling you what the scene was
in boulder at the time
the boulder broker wasn't as young
as the fac i think it was a hilton or
something
the boulder broker was a more
experienced crowd you know realtors
that type of you know jerk offs but at
the end of the week they would just get
rooms and go upstairs and [__]
it was no big thing sunday they had the
brunch
tuesd sunday night the broker had
a steak and two movies don't ask me how
they did it
i'm not here to throw nobody under the
bus it was 30 [__] years ago
so on tuesday nights you ready for this
on
tuesday nights on sunday nights you
could put pajamas on
hoodies [__] slippers you could go to
the broker
give them 15 bucks and the first movie
started at six
like it was like a double feature in the
restaurant okay
they had little chairs that you could
put and put your feet on top of them so
you could sit back
i'm not kidding and after for dessert
was hot cocoa
with marshmallows in it for you to watch
the [__] movie they weren't [__]
around they always have cute little
double features
whatever was i down there no i i never
had gone into the broker
i think i'd gone there one time for
brunch with my in-laws
before i even married them they invited
me on a sunday
[__] tremendous i had about 19
glasses of freshly squeezed orange juice
everything was for free on the brunch
except the orange you lose
juice each glass was like seven bucks i
must have rang up like 140 in our
freshly squeezed our issues my in-laws
were living but anyway
i open up this [__] article and i see
that
the broker is doing a [__] contest
for comedy right away you guys know
my [__] shrinking are tightened up i
closed the [__] newspaper
and i said i'm not going down in because
i'm a [__] [__]
i'm not gonna go down there and [__]
lose
but you know the switch
still hadn't gone off yet i was just
like in a [__]
29 year old limbo you know i was 28
i was like 28 yeah i was 28
i just started into comedy
me and my wife weren't doing well you
know i was working a lot of hours
i was sneaking a little bit of cocaine
you know
i was trying to tell people i was sober
but i really wasn't
i really wanted to be a comic but
just my past and who the [__] i was in
my dna
i just didn't think i could do it but i
looked at this ad
rolled the broker joker and i called a
friend of mine a very dear friend of
mine
still friend of mine maddie tomina i'm
going to give him a call today
he knew the people at the broker he was
dear friends with one of the managers
and i said call him up and ask him if i
go down there tonight and do the
or ask him if i go down there and
watch the contest you know me i'm a big
time [__] can i watch
the contest and within 10 minutes he
called back and he goes no no no no
he needs contestants for tonight
do you mind doing a set it's [__]
three in the afternoon guys
i wasn't experienced i didn't know what
i was gonna say
or what i was gonna write so i said
okay i don't know where it came from
it wasn't the joey diaz that was who he
was then
i go okay i'll i'll do it and
i call i answer i hung up the phone
and i'm just i'm happy if i'll [__]
make it down there
and i wrote a few jokes together i don't
know how many minutes it was guys maybe
five
maybe seven i don't know what it was
and i think it was like september 18th
september 15th
and i went down there not expecting
anything you know what i went down there
to expect
i went down there to expect to lose be
humiliated
and do what i was usually used to doing
quitting
everything i did i [__] quit but
something else happened
i ended up going down there there was
maybe four other comics up
you know there was maybe 20 people in
the audience
because that's all that went tuesday
nights was comedy night they had just
started and they were trying to boost it
i got the story later on they had been
dabbling in comedy for about six months
but they could never really get it going
so they got bex to be a company to do
well bex was doing them anyway at that
time
was doing a large comedy competition
they had scaled it down they had scaled
it down from a national comedy
competition
to a regional comedy competition so for
me it was like
new mexico wyoming montana
i don't know exactly what the breakdown
was i know
phoenix arizona was involved
so he goes can you just come up and do
the contest and i said
absolutely guys i don't know what i
wrote
i don't know what i said i would love to
be able to tell you i taped the set
you know i don't know who was up there
all i know is
that i went up there and at the end of
the night they said the winner is
joey diaz and i [__] [__] my pants
not literally i was like how the [__]
did i win this
you know was i really and i didn't know
anybody
i didn't i just went up there i sat
there by myself
with my little [__] pussy-ass self
and i just went up there and i did the
jokes i
wrote and i won and i go what do i win
the guy goes nothing you just get to
come back
in october and i'm like really
come on and that's like i was like [__]
so i'm like i better tighten my [__] up
and it wasn't like
it is today well not today today
december 2020 it's not like it is today
you know before the pandemic with comedy
that there was a thousand places i could
go to in boulder there was basically no
place
to really you know i had heard about how
comics work out
that's what i had learned when i had
worked the door it would send
how comics work out and you know you
take a joke and process it
i was ready to do all this i i didn't
really know what i was doing
but there was really nowhere to go and
boulder to
rehearse so i think one saturday i went
to that room like i
told you about it was like all the way
on the other side and [__] denver and
littleton
and the show started at 11 the guy
wouldn't put me up at one
that's not really good for your [__]
self-image
and your self-confidence i went down
there i got beat up
you know same [__] emotional beat up
long drive back and
one of the guys from the halfway house
had a girlfriend
that had a coffee shop called penny lane
and he gave me an idea he goes just go
to the poetry readings
and do what you can do material i mean
listen guys that
if that's what it was i had two options
i could either put a [__] mirror
and stand in front of a mirror like a
zoom show or
[__] go to this poetry
and i went to the poetry thing and it
was pretty interesting so that i looked
online you know
online i looked in the [__] paper and
i noticed that they had open mics
for poetry every [__] night
i would try to get in there you know i
was i'd already been fired from the
cowboys
uh not from the kelvins there was a
comedy called wits end
i had already been fired from them i was
not really happy in my marriage
and every night i would look for ways to
go to different places
guys i it got to the point where i would
walk into [__]
uh joints and they would say
listen you came last week we can't have
your style of comedy in here
you're not a very good comedian please
don't come back i mean
that was told right to my face i never
raised my hand i never got mad at them
i knew what can i do i'm not going to
argue with these people
but then something happened october 15th
i [__] walked in the door and my
ex-wife told me that
she found the bill and she wanted to get
separated
and i accepted it and i was heartbroken
about the kid
but to be honest i was [__] excited
that now i could do comedy so somewhere
along the line i went in october
and performed again with everything that
was on my mind
and boom guess what joey diaz got his
hand raised again
i didn't [__] know i don't even know
what i said again i just went down there
but this time some people had gone down
to see me
i was working on a sports betting
service so like
13 guys went to see me and when they all
clapped
i got the [__] i won the night not
bad
i could live with that right okay
a bunch of [__] goes on you know after
october 15th
uh i'm picking my daughter up every day
at the [__] daycare and
holding it you know so my ex-wife would
get out of work that was
how i spent my time with her and then i
would feed her
and then kathy mike's wife would pick
her up and then i would just
you know try to go to an open mic or
i would try to go to music open mics and
they would tell me
you could do five minutes you know it
was just a [__] struggle
in boulder it was there wasn't much
there was a few rock clubs
around the area and i would contact them
and they would say we never heard of you
you know if you were this comic or this
comic or this kind of
which they weren't famous either it was
just they had local notoriety in the
area
he goes if one of them called for you
whatever so i was just struggling with
my [__] comedy
and the whole thing
so november i had no [__] idea how i
won that contest
i really don't remember what i said or
i had now all these comics i was going
up against
i had never seen one of them i had never
ever seen any other
other any of these guys the comics i was
saying
when i was going to denver they were
good
they were good these young comics that
were when i say young i'm not talking
about 20
i'm talking about young early in that
comedy career
so early on in the comedy career i knew
these guys and i was like
if these [__] show up to
boulder
i'm not winning [__] i'm just dying
but november's contest was different
because instead of 17 people coming to
see me
like 30 people came to see me
and that's the night i realized what
happened was i was running behind
i was running behind on time uh
once my wife left i lost my job as a
roofer
i didn't want to sell cars anymore i
just wanted to really focus on stand-up
i had a little money put away at 29
credit cards i wasn't concerned with
money
i was just consumed with [__]
stand-up comedy that's all i gave a [__]
about
uh i was trying to do it every night
blah blah blah blah blah
you know it wasn't working whatever i
pulled off this this november win
because i was running late at that time
i
got into selling a little bit of drugs
and one of the drugs i started selling
was
valium and
it's or drug coke coke heads
love valium because at four in the
morning when they gotta go to sleep they
gotta eat these [__] vs
i was getting these v's on longmont they
had the v
in them the original old school volume
forget about i was getting them for like
60 cents a piece
and selling them for like three dollars
a piece
i was getting rid of a hundred of those
things every two [__] days in boulder
but part of my action was having people
meet me
at the clubs i'm going there to do you
know i had already done time
i had to be a little careful i had to be
a reason
for me to be there so i would like hide
the [__] pills in the trunk
and pull up and go in first and then
come out and take the pills out and go
back in
i was like really cautious and i knew if
they caught me with 10 pills
i wasn't gonna do kidnapping time you
know
so i just kept it under i sold little
weed
i saw i i was dealing with this guy up
in the [__] mountains
that grew the best weed in the world i
think i forget where he lived
before esther's park and i would go up
there once a week he would make me two
eggs
with wheat to multi-grain toast and red
beans
i had never had a breakfast like that i
would give him money and he would give
me a
a soda container uh a cracker container
like i have upstairs
with a pound of wheat that was [__]
tremendous
i was selling weed you know i didn't
have a job i was selling valium
i was starting to uh i wasn't
dating women or anything my wife and i
had made a deal when she left october
15th
not to date anybody until we decided
what our fate was if we were going to
get a divorce
or we were going to stay together
boulder was a small community
and we didn't want nobody [__] uh you
know we didn't want to hurt each other
so i was cool with that i didn't need i
didn't need to screw nobody to do
nothing
i was just happy that i had comedy i
wasn't going to be
you know married anymore or i was going
to be married
i didn't know what was going on i was
just happy that something else
beside drugs and crimes and stupid
[__] jobs have been thrown on my lap
i was just [__] excited that i had
finally tried [__] comedy and here i
was in a contest
and here we [__] are so we get the
[__] december the finals are december
18th
i'm fired up i got the judy counter
worker book
i got the jean parade comedy workbook i
got the other gene parade workbook
i'm writing garbage i don't even know
what the [__] i'm writing
i love to sit here and tell you i was
writing these jokes that were deep
i was writing garbage i was just a funny
[__] guy
and i kept trying to bang it out but
december was the moment of truth
december was created to [__] kill me
that year
december came at me like a [__]
vicious
you know everything first of all she
calls me up and she's like listen i
think that
we're gonna stay separated for a while
and i'm gonna get my own apartment
do you mind if i [__]
come down there and get some stuff with
my father and my brother
just so i could have stuff in my
apartment and i'm like yeah
how bad could it be what does she want a
couch
we had two tvs we had like the crib the
bedroom
we had a living room set we had this
whole this whole outdoor patio set
that was like a green room that half of
it was out but half of it was in
if you wanted to grow [__] flowers it
was tremendous my little condo
i found this condom myself there's a
mortal story to this but
we'll go into that later how i got this
condo
i said sure i go as a matter of fact
i'm such a gentleman i'll leave you
alone i won't even be there
just go over there take what you need
and i'm fine with it this
is not my the finals is december 18th
this has to be like december 14th
i walk into my [__] house
and guys all that was left
was a tv stand a tv
a vcr
i looked in the kitchen everything was
gone
to the [__] the dinner table
the piece where you have your dishes in
there and there was a picture of our
wedding
you know i don't know what people call
those we had some other [__] in there
that was gone i go into the kitchen
[__] the little coffee table was gone
i went out into the [__] sun room
everything was gone except my [__]
desk
plants pictures on the wall
i turned around all the pictures were
gone
i [__] run upstairs to the bathroom
my toothbrush
was laying there with a little travel
tube a toothpaste
and a little bit of listerine everything
else she had taken the towels
the soap the cup for the [__] soap
i went into the [__] bedroom and all
that was left in the bedroom
was a mattress on top of a box springs
the dirty [__] even took
the [__] thing with the rollers in
the bottom of the bed
so you could roll it there was no
armoire
there was no cabinets all my clothes was
on the [__] floor
and the indoor closet was empty my
clothes were in
her clothes was gone listen i i looked
around i'm like
okay i guess this is what separation is
i went downstairs to get a [__] soda
guys she had taken the sodas
whatever food was in there that was like
still fresh she took
all that she left it was like let's say
there was a jar of orange juice
that was half full empty she left that
i went to look she stole the [__]
mustard
who takes the [__] mustard
i didn't know what to do i didn't know
what to do
4 30 came i [__] walked up to the
daycare
i picked up my daughter jackie i walked
back home
and we basically sat in the living room
on [__] milk grades
i think we ended up going i took it to
like cocos there was a restaurant across
the street
and she got like a hamburger and stuff
and when
at 6 30 came home my wife came because
my wife would get over there like at
6 15 every night to pick up the baby
she shows up like at 6 20. i'm like
where is everything
and she goes listen man i i got to start
a new apartment
you're making money you could start from
scratch
i took what i thought was mine you know
i threw a little bit of a fit
but it wasn't a [__] you know but she
took everything
this is three days before my [__]
contest
and then i get a [__] i
you know i get like a letter in the mail
that
she's filing for all these like half the
[__] we had discussed
was completely different you know
and then it's the night of the [__]
contest
i don't have to tell you where my head
was at i woke up at six in the morning
i don't think i slept the night before i
was [__] petrified
[__] petrified i was like i'm not
going down to that finals tonight
i'm not gonna go down there [__] that
i'm done with comedy
i'm not a canadian i'm a [__]
criminal
my wife just left me she took all the
[__] [__] she took the mustard
i don't have the [__] i don't know
what it takes i've just been lying to
myself
this has just been [__] this has
just been a [__] story
i'm never gonna amount to nothing i'm
never gonna [__] be a comic or go on
a tour i'm never gonna do
none of these [__] things you know
i was just down on myself man i was like
what the [__]
this is never gonna happen i worked all
these years
like i've gone to prison i've been a
[__] a mess
and for the last two years i've been
just working on myself little by little
yeah i still had a little bit of a
[__] drug problem but i had been
working on myself as a human being
like towards something like i i i became
a roofing estimate and i was good at it
i
i was you know i got a job at a comedy
club
i was paying attention it wasn't like i
was running around like a [__] indian
finally i was starting to get a little
[__] control of my life i would go
watch comedy
i knew it was you know i didn't want to
start something without knowing and then
just quitting
i wanted to do something just right at
[__] 28 years i've been doing every
[__] thing wrong
and i just wanted to do something
[__] right so i said you know what
i'm gonna stop with this [__] [__] i'm
gonna stop with this resistance as they
talk about with the art of war
or the war of art in that book by
stephen pressman this is i
didn't even know about that [__] then
guys i just knew my life had to change
the switch had not turned i was just at
war
myself and i had to win this [__] war
so i said you know what
i'm gonna go down to this [__]
contest tonight i
went at 4 30 i picked up my [__]
daughter
you know we ordered chinese food i
forgot i had no [__] silverware
no [__] forks to eat i had nothing
i'm [__] sitting there
i'm so embarrassed in front of this
child i had to like knock on a
neighbor's door
and get like two forks first i promised
i'd bring him back i told her that
our dishwasher broke i don't know what
[__] excuse i made
i'm supposed to she's supposed to drop
the contest starts at eight
she's supposed to drop off she's
supposed to pick up my daughter
at 6 15 i'm gonna take a shower
i'm going to go to a restaurant or
whatever meet a friend of mine
who's going to look at my jokes with me
you know at this time i called him my
manager
i still love him i still talked to him i
had my little
by that time i had my own little
entourage by the way i didn't tell you
about that
i had my man danny i had his wife mayday
i had a guy from my building i had uh
my boy from buffalo mckenna you know i
had my own little [__] entourage
so on tuesday nights they would go down
there and cheer me on
that whole [__] day i was making
people calling me for drugs
like where can we get coke where can we
get weed where can we get [__]
malukia pills
i said listen everything happens at the
broker tonight at eight o'clock
coke heroin [__] inflatable [__]
whatever you need it's gonna be at the
broker tonight at eight o'clock
i just needed people down there for me
to win this [__] contest
like i said all is fair in love and war
i could look you straight in the face
today and tell you i didn't cheat
i actually worked i sat down i wrote
[__] jokes
i tried to even add a tag i had put my
first tag
i'd probably been on stage at this point
maybe 35 times
that's that's stretching the imagination
maybe 35 times i had been on the [__]
stage
i told everybody meet me down there at
eight i'll take care of all you
i got an eight ball there was a guy
[__] that looked around the corner from
me i called him up
he had an eight ball ready for me i had
volumes you know i don't even know what
else i was selling at the time
i was like a one-man demolition but all
i had on my mind was this contest now
between you and i guys
i would have won the war against myself
just by showing up and i knew this
i knew this for me to win this war for
me to beat
joey diaz the loser and become joey d
as the winner i have to just show up
this is why i tell you guys you just got
to show up that's after battle
just show up let the pieces fall where
they may
just show up show up show up [__]
6 30. my wife ain't there
6 45 my wife isn't there it's the
biggest night of my [__] life
i'm gonna finally go to war for myself
i'm finally doing something to move
ahead
i'm finally towards i'm finally moving
towards turning on that switch
which i never knew existed at the time
by the way
none of these guys knew we had the
swords like that
existed [__] seven o'clock
she knocks on my [__] door my ex-wife
i'm like where the [__] have you been
you know what this dirty [__] tells me
miss catholic miss don't date nobody she
goes i went on a date
for a drink i go time out
you just been telling me for the last
month and a half
not to go on a date that i can't [__]
that i can't [__] uh i want to date
that you don't want to be embarrassed
that your dad's a big realtor in town
she goes i change my mind
you change your mind just like that
my feelings were a little hurt i'm like
[__] really
okay you know i didn't ask for nothing
i probably had a tear in my eye or too
you know i was expecting something it
wasn't that i was in love
it wasn't that i missed her or anything
like that it was just
i thought we had a [__] uh an
agreement you know
she tasted my kiss my you know was
snowy out like take the baby chip my
daughter was probably
two maybe a year and a half two years at
the time
i take the i carry it downstairs in the
snow i put her in the [__] car
you know i'm a little taken back you
know
i [__] mock up the carriage i smoke a
half a joint
i get in my car and i go down to the
[__] broker now i'm [__] living
i get to the broker all my friends are
there hey how you doing you got my
pills you got my coke i'm selling
everything
they go all the comedians come to the
table
we come over to this table there's like
seven of us in the final
i still remember two of the guys that
were there now
this was an amateur competition
what that meant was that you could have
not
done either an emcee a feature
or a headlining spot anywhere for money
you could be an open micro all right
so i get there and i already you know me
i'm not a crime stopper
i'm not a [__] i get there and i go
holy [__] there's two comics here
that should not be here i know for a
fact they have gotten paid before
they're on flyers whatever
did i say anything i don't say a [__]
word
now i'm still [__] coming down off
the [__] anger
and pain you know and just
disappointment that my wife had laid on
me
you know i i had no [__] mustard
i got no silverware you know what i'm
saying i mean i got
a ton of [__] things in my mind and
right now at this moment when i see
these two guys there
and i see the lineup right away i want
to pull up joey diaz and turn around and
leave
and i'll never forget that i actually
took like a step back
and was ready to [__] but i saw all
the friends like that can't
you know what they weren't my friends
they were [__] customers
but like 50 of them were really my
friends i think i put like 100 people in
there that night
you know and i see all this [__] that's
going on like all these
you know comics and they're getting into
arguments amongst themselves
so now i go you know what i'm gonna go
to the bar and have a soda
and call this a [__] night you know
whatever go on stage
who the [__] am i i'm never gonna be a
[__] comic and you're not gonna
believe
what happens next one of the judges
comes up to me and he goes
i think you're disqualified and i go
what are you talking about and he goes
because
one of the guys said that you did a show
for the broncos
and he did it with you and they gave you
five dollars for gas
i go five dollars for
gas exactly from greeley
to boulder it wasn't even gas money that
paid for [__]
the first two miles what are you talking
about
because they i didn't know this when i
had gone over to the bar
they had gone into an argument amongst
themselves about who wasn't an amateur
and who wasn't
and i'm like i i didn't even listen i
didn't even know that argument was going
on
so all of a sudden had disqualified two
of them and the one guy
said if i get disqualified diaz gets
disqualified
because he took five dollars [__] you
[__] you've been taking money
like you've been getting 50s and 25s
i wasn't even up to that level so now
the contest had been cut down to five
from seven right there there's already
[__] controversy
and the one guy came close to me he
wanted a [__] like
he didn't want to fight me but he wanted
to argue with me and i'm like
i got no time to [__] argue right in
the mood i'm in
i just want to eat chinese food i didn't
have a [__] fork
the mood i'm in i will rip your [__]
eyeball out
get the [__] away from me i don't think
that guy ever spoke to me again
i saw him in open mics after that he
could tell i was on fire that night
after
after the [__] day i had you're gonna
tell me now that i can't do this [__]
contest
because i took five dollars [__] six
months ago for [__] gas money
i could tell if he gave me a hundred or
150 i would have done the right thing
and said i'm not an amateur
it's the truth i did get paid at 150 and
i would have bowed out
but [__] you i'm fight for what i
[__] believe in it was five dollars
for gas
and gas is really like twelve dollars so
what the [__] are you talking about
finally they smoothened it out everybody
went to that neutral corner i don't know
you know man i must have said a prayer
to myself and i said it i go you know
what
and that's when i put the continuing
continuance
into that sentence i won the war
by coming down here with myself no
matter what happens even if i come in
the last
i won [__] you
i'm coming down here to win this whole
[__] thing
i felt like what's that behringer tom
behringer
in [__] major league when they say
that
you know they're gonna get traded you're
gonna be horrible
and he goes then we just got one [__]
option
and that's to win this whole [__]
thing
and i'll never forget where i was and
that broken the door was like over there
the bar was over there the stage was
right over here
the audience was here and i was deep
deep deep over here in a corner looking
out the window at the traffic
and i'll never forget looking at that
audience looking at the other four
comedians and going you know what
nah i didn't come down here [__] around
with these [__]
i came down here to win this whole
[__] thing and guess what happened
they put me up like i mean they put me
up like first
they did everything they could to [__]
with me but on that particular night
remember i told you guys i did the
[__] album thing
on the cover of dr dre his first album
look at that picture
on that day on that day i don't know
about today
today he just got one a billion dollars
from [__] beats
i don't know if he wants to be president
of the united states
but i know on that day when he took that
picture
he could have been the president of the
united states on that night
i could have done whatever i wanted to
do
because it all started in my mind i go
this is exactly what i'm doing
yeah i won my personal battle we all
have personal battles
and that's what half years are going
through right now
it's not the world that's against you
it's that you're against you and by you
stacking the odds against you on your
own that makes your situation even worse
at that moment the odds were all on me
you know what my odds were
i was an all-time favorite i was going
in there
giving [__] 90 000 [__] points
do you understand me so i
[__] went up there first against
everybody they were all giggling at me
like haha you're gonna go up first
you're gonna eat the biggest dick guess
what
those 130 [__] people went [__]
nuts when i went up there
the response was tremendous guess what
else
nobody had a better set than i did that
night nobody
nobody i had a five minute set that was
flawless
again if i could remember a joke i would
lay it on him but this
it was just stupid [__] jokes i don't
know what it did
the pieces fell together
this other comic had brought a bunch of
other people they were cheering him
on but pound for pound i was better than
him
like you know fundamentally at that time
i was better than him at the end of the
night they raised my hand
and they said joey diaz you won 500
[__] dollars
and that's tonight that's the [__]
night i won the war that was the first
war
i ever won against myself i had been
homeless i had been in prison
i had gone through so many [__]
things
but it wasn't about the 500 it wasn't
about the launch
pad because it didn't really launch me
nowhere it's not like
they put me on mtv or nbc after that
that night december 18th i will [__]
cherish
this friday night i will eat 20 [__]
edibles out of respect for you
[__]
because like i told you the universe
will always take care of you
if you put the work in and you believe
and you
actually look in the mirror and go [__]
these [__]
and you could say it like there's people
who say it all the time [__] people
[__] no you got to believe it
when you believe it when you say it and
you go [__] these like i swear to god
i'm not making this up
i'll never forget looking out that
window i don't know if it was snowing or
not
at traffic and looking at that thing and
going no
i didn't come down in just a [__]
place
i'm coming down here to wipe my [__]
ass with these [__]
and that's exactly what i did so before
you know i know that some people are
down
i know that some people are frustrated i
know that you're broke
i know that you have a loss that's all
great and dandy
a lot of other people are going through
what i was going through then
what's my next [__] move this is what
i want to do
and then you start throwing things at
yourself to confuse yourself
and you're out of it you've you you you
didn't even get to the [__]
you didn't even get to the battlefield
you stopped yourself before you got to
the battlefield
don't stop yourself before you go to a
battlefield this is a war every day
this is why i get up on a monday and i
tell you [__] you got to go out
like a [__] animal
because this is a war and it's not a war
against stan it's not a war against your
boss
it's not a war against a record label
it's not a war against the plumbing
union
or the teachers union it's the war that
you have to win against yourself
you have to beat that side that tells
you
you can't do it the side that tells you
there's a side of me too that's a little
[__] [__] even today
at 58 i had this little [__] side
that's why the ekg
that's why because i got that little
[__] side of me
that still doubt and a little fear but
i usually go back to december 18th
because that was the night
the switch didn't go off it was the
first thing
i won the battle against myself you got
to win the war against yourself
before that switch goes off what do you
think about that [__]
and that's december 14th
2020 on a beautiful [__]
day if that story doesn't help you
[__]
grab the world by the balls listen just
go upstairs and spray raid down your
throat
and end it with some bug cleaner you
know what i'm saying they'll never find
in the autopsy
i had a great weekend this weekend i
hope you enjoyed the ufc fights
[__] moreno against gastolino
whatever his name was
was a fight for the [__] books uh
i always knew that jackaray was going to
lose
and the other old-timer junior was going
to lose
the main fight on the card that i wanted
to watch the card with
was for oliveira against uh
my man didn't turn his way
oliver is a rising star but it was a
great weekend all in all
and now i can't believe there's no ufc
card december 29th
i think it's next saturday and that's it
so that's why we're stuck after the 23rd
so we're going to be doing a lot of
couple little things
and uh that's it and that's that
remember
before the switch could turn you got to
win the war against yourself
that's the first thing the battle within
yourself
that battle that we have inside of us
that goes back and forth
once you win that the world is your
oyster
you'll get your [__] licked on a
daily basis you understand me
and that's it and that's that thank you
for watching on a beautiful monday
morning it's snowing out
but i don't give a [__] you're my job i
love you guys
and don't forget to visit me on three
five and
seven fifteen the shirts got [__]
sent
out they're this color the color of
happiness you think i'm wearing this
color on a monday
because i'm going to a [__] no i'm
wearing this color because
it transforms happiness
we're happy today i love you
[__] enjoy the ads
thank you very much wednesday uncle
vinnie's
that's it and that's that have a great
[__] week
we'll be back here wednesday morning
ready to rock stay black
all right i want to thank you
[__] for listening on a
beautiful monday morning
i want to read something to you people
want to talk to you people about some uh
way you can save some money over the
holidays it's with honey
listen with so many gifts you got to buy
right now
between your whole family your wives
your cousins
you know the girl at the that the
shopping center you always want to
listen you want to be generous
what if i told you i'd get you a little
help i'm paying for all this
well that's what honey is doing to help
them pay
for 1 million bucks worth of gifts the
only way santa's coming down your
chimney
if is he if he's covered in honey this
is the same honey that automatically
searches
for promo codes online it's easy just
add honey to your computer
ready for this create an account and
throw some gifts on your drop list
for a chance to win you get randomly
selected to win the money
you need for anything on your list
listen man
mercy needs a bunch of stuff i don't
even know what how to start i went
down to the mall yesterday oh my god
anxiety 101.
forget about all that get these uh
promo codes online and you don't have to
leave your house
it's it's it's like stealing plastic
honey they'll tell you when the price
drops
for anything on your list which is a
plus right there
do me a favor go to honey right now for
free today join honey.com
joey create your list for a chance to
win
here's the lawyer part you ready no
purchase is necessary
all you need is a paypal account to
redeem your prize only valid
in the u.s giveaway ends 12
21 of 2020 that's next week
so go to honey right now today join it
for free
no purchase necessary but you can only
win
at joinhoney.com
joey the joint is also brought to you by
mac
world right now listen they're bringing
men's basics around whether it's the
warm knit top
or the sunday lounge pants everyone on
your list is going to be [__]
comfortable
i love mack wilden comfort
quality style they got all the
essentials socks
shirts hoodies underwears mac welding is
comfortable
and versatile you can wear it at the gym
at a show at a dinner it works
everywhere
wait till they see me at the supermarket
with my mac welding long underwear on
you understand me
with the little [__] crease in the
middle they're gonna lose their mind
i don't give a [__] i used to go outside
with long underwear all the time
it freaks people out but we do what we
do
all their clothes feature a range of
custom fabrics
like anti-microbial silver and with
their loyalty program if you spend 200
now you'll get 20 off on every order you
make next year
listen this is the way to go get ish
got your shopping in today right now
monday the 14th
and save next year mack walden wants you
to be comfortable
so if you don't like your first pair of
underwear
you can keep them and they'll still
refund you
that's what i'm talking about no
questions asked
what the [__] are you waiting for go to
mack walden now
and get a pair win the gift-giving
season this season
listener you want to be popular in your
family you want people to say dog
he gives out good gifts go to mack
walden right now and get 20
off your first order visit
mackweldon.com
join and at the promo code join that's
mackwalden.com
and enter promo code joint for 20
percent
off mac weldon reinventing men's under
basics what do you mean underwear shirts
hoodies everything
macweldon.com here you go [__]
listen it's christmas you're showing up
with a big dick and a [__] smile on
your face
who needs a red hat like santa [__]
santa as long as you got a big dick
you're the [__] man all right listen
we're going through rough times right
now with stressful
people under the weather you haven't
really been thinking about your heart on
but it's the holiday season it's the 12
dies days of christmas
you got you start getting your dick
sucked by the 23rd and you go straight
to the second of january
that that's what i'm talking about here
you're young you're [__] very
get out there but listen you don't want
to [__] show up with a dick
with a gun with four bullets when you
carry 18 right
this is why we're working with bluetooth
forget about it your dick looks like a
[__] bongo stick
their [__] blue chew is prescribed
online
by licensed physicians so you don't have
to go to the doctor's office
and wait online like a [__] mooc and
then people look at you
and it ships right to your door in a
discrete package
nobody knows nothing it's the first
chewable dick bill
same fda approved active ingredients as
viagra
and cialis i love this stuff this ain't
the [__] they sell you down
at some [__] grocery store on the
corner of bodega by a guy named [__]
poopoo
that's selling some [__] pill no no
no no no this is the real deal
this is blue chew they don't play games
so right now i want you to go to
bluetooth.com that's blue b-l-u-e like
the
color of your helmet when you don't get
[__] when you don't get [__] for like
a year your dick
starts to turn weird a couple more
months it's just gonna [__] fall off
we ain't doing that here we're slinging
dick in 2020
and slinging dick going into 2021
with blue chew right now today
bluetooth.com and get your first
shipment free
when you're pressing code joey you pay
five hours
five hours for shipping and again that's
bluetooth
that's it dot com use code joey
blueshoe.com use code joey never show up
with a 60 dick again everybody's happy
if she's not walking around with
crutches the next day
you didn't do your job you understand me
that's what blue chew comes in
bluechew.com i want to thank bluechu
i want to thank matt weldon and i want
to thank honey but most importantly
i want to thank you [__] for
giving me the opportunity to be here me
and my man mike
and i love you guys and i'll see you
wednesday morning tip top magoo with no
[__] stories
stay black have a great day uncle joey
loves you
there you go i still got it [__]
you